vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est un pas en
avant pour les infirmiers mais on est
quand même loin des super infirmières
qui l ont plus de responsabilités plus
de pouvoirs aussi oui on les appelle les
infirmières praticiennes et même
certaines infirmières praticiennes
spécialisées
comment le devient temps mais il faut
d'abord être infirmière pratiquer
quelques années ensuite on retourne à
l'université pour faire une maîtrise
c'est comme ça qu'on devient une ip est
si vous voulez alors y'en a combien au
canada mais selon les chiffres de 2014
en fait encore lada il y en avait quatre
1155 la majeure partie sont localisés en
ontario plus de la moitié en fait
ensuite suivent loin derrière l'alberta
et la colombie-britannique et vous allez
voir que le québec est quand même pas
mal en arrière puisque au québec qu'il y
en avait juste 253 c'est un choix de la
province puisque c'est le gouvernement
qui en fait choisi le nombre et qui
limite aussi l'accès à cette profession
c'est spécial donc elles font la même
chose ici au québec qu'ailleurs au pays
pas tout à fait en fait si on regarde ce
que peut faire en général au canada ces
fameuses infirmières elles peuvent
prescrire la plupart des médicaments
elles peuvent commander et interpréter
des tests de laboratoires d analyses
commandées également des rayons x des
ultrasons de l'imagerie et poser des
diagnostics mais si on regarde en fait
ce qu'elles font au québec et biya
plusieurs limites par exemple on ne fait
pas un diagnostic mais on va poser une
impression on diagnostique alors c'est
un peu de sémantique mais c'est a toute
son importance pour différencier le
québec du reste du canada
elles ont un pouvoir de prescription
limitée pour certaines certaines
médications elles ne peuvent pas faire
admettre un patient à l'hôpital où même
lui donner son congé et puis surtout
elles doivent être liées à un médecin
alors vous voyez qu'il ya quand même eu
un lien important ici qui doit être
maintenue au québec également dans les
maritimes mais ailleurs dans le reste du
canada
il n'y a pas du tout ce besoin de
partenariat avec un médecin qu'on leur
fait plus confiance
ailleurs au canada et en terme de
salaire est ce que c'est la même chose
mais en fait non c'est ça quand on
regarde un peu quand on compare
justement garder l'alberta 87000 quand
on commence en bas de l'échelle ça va
jusqu'à 127 9 97 mille pardons jusqu'à
127 milles regardez c'est assez
similaire en colombie-britannique
nouveau brunswick 82000 ontario 75000
jusqu'à 120 milles et regardées au
québec
une infirmière praticienne va seulement
chercher entre 53 et 94000 94000 en fait
on commence déjà à 97 milles
en alberta alors c'est évidemment une
autre source de beaucoup de frustration
pour ces infirmières plutôt spécial est
encore un peu de chemin à faire mais ça
m'a pris